en Dinamarca lo llaman el proyecto del
siglo un archipiélago artificial surgirá
aquí en el estrecho de oro es un frente
a copenhague en el año 2070 El objetivo
evitar que la subida de las aguas del
mar sumerja la capital con una altitud
media de solo 34 metros sobre el nivel
del mar Dinamarca es uno de los países
más bajos del mundo
aquí tienes la presa y luego este
espacio de aquí será la parte de
protección los responsables del proyecto
afirman que la Península de linete Hold
funcionará con una parte remota que
protegerá la capital donde vivo una
quinta parte de la población del país
La Isla estará al nivel del mar más 4
metros
y en la parte oriental donde se
encuentra el Mar habrá un paisaje de
hasta 6 metros para protegerse de las
olas
desde el siglo 17 copenhague ha crecido
sobre el agua Gracias a las Islas
artificiales esta península que se
extiende a lo largo de 3 kilómetros
cuadrados ofrece 35.000 viviendas pero
justo cuando comienza la primera fase de
construcción del jinete los ecologistas
ya dan la voz de alarma
el lugar donde estamos navegando tiene
la misma biodiversidad que la gran
Barrera de coral de Australia es la gran
Barrera de coral de Europa y lo que
estamos haciendo ahora es destruirla
ahora ya tenemos esta sustancia venenosa
corriendo en nuestro cuerpo
los habitantes de la ciudad están
preocupados según una encuesta sólo el
3% de ellos aprueba el proyecto que
costará los contribuyentes unos 2500
millones de euros pase lo que pase
copenhague necesita protección con o sin
leche en proyecto
[Música]
hay que proteger la Cuenca del puerto ya
sea con diques o con la isla Line tejón
y también habrá algún tipo de compuertas
similares por ejemplo a lo que se ha
hecho en Venecia
el año que viene empezarán a construir
los contornos de la Península del inete
Home se necesitarán más de 100 metros
cúbicos de tierra para que salga del
estrecho de orson